july is national minority mental health
awareness month and intermountain
healthcare the sponsors of this next
segment are focusing on mental
well-being for diverse populations so
leticia morgan with intermountain
healthcare is here to tell us more and
educate us on this topic how are you i'm
well how are you doing i'm good good to
see you again last time we were in the
actual behavioral clinic now you're here
yes so just tell everybody what you do
specifically for and around healthcare
so i'm a licensed clinical social worker
part of our mental health integration
team where we provide individual and
group therapy also we have psychiatric
nurse practitioners that provide
medication management for our clients
amazing and why is it so important to
have a national month for minority in
particular mental health awareness you
know to
really raise awareness and bring more
education because we find that the
disparities in these groups it's
the more you know and the more that it's
put out there we can break those stigmas
and it really helps them say okay it's
okay for me to come in or this is
available for me absolutely and how is
mental not mental intermountain
healthcare helping this this cause
so we just recently opened up a new
clinic on cheyenne
and it is dedicated to behavioral health
we also provide primary care there as
well but we're looking at the whole
person we're not just addressing their
physical health but we're also
addressing their mental health we're
seeing we saw some footage of you guys
in the offices you know when someone
wants to come in
what's the process like with you guys so
they're usually referred to us by their
primary care provider or they can be a
self-referral okay
once that happens we do an intake with
them and we go through and kind of
identify what the needs are
and we either refer them to medication
management or we address it as the
therapist and if someone's watching who
has been struggling with their mental
health you know what are some of the
signs that they should look out for you
know
when you're struggling within a hall
things change in your habits you become
more isolated or withdrawn
and so people should just really take a
note of what's happening with their
friends and families did something
change or they're a little bit more
quiet
than normal okay and with all the things
going on in the world
you know in the minority communities
consuming constantly this news and
violence and justices you know that
doesn't help either so how do you how do
you suggest people deal with that you
know taking a moment to take a break
sometimes disconnecting to just kind of
get in touch with yourself yeah and
really taking self-care is really
important during this time
it is um vital really for you to kind of
disconnect from social media absolutely
and to come and speak to someone it's
really nice to talk to someone who's not
connected to the things that you are
looking at and those social determinants
really quick to end in the segment just
list them off so people understand yes
so that's your housing that's your food
insecurities your access to health care
transportation so those are things that
we also address at intermountain to help
break these barriers perfect well thank
you so much for what you at intermittent
healthcare does for the community thank
you again for sponsoring this segment as
well for more information just visit
intermountainhealthcare.org
nevada
[Music]